[Music]
your head hurts your nauseating your
achy and you are certainly never
drinking again
the only thought running through your
foggy mind is why are hangovers the
absolute worst
[Music]
let's go back to last night as you down
that cocktail alcohol migrates through
your GI tract to your liver where
enzymes break it down but as you
continue to drink your liver can't keep
up so the alcohol overflows into your
bloodstream and travels to other organs
like your brain there it suppresses a
hormone called vasopressin normally
vasopressin prevents you from urinating
too much so without it you have to pee
all the time dehydrating you in the
process and that helps explain your
brutal headache the next morning but
there are other chemicals at work such
as pro-inflammatory cytokines these are
small proteins that stimulate
inflammation which causes symptoms like
nausea jitters and headaches and people
who are hungover have tons of them in
their blood in fact when researchers
injected pro-inflammatory cytokines into
people who were stone-cold sober they
actually felt hungover without all the
fun beforehand what a ripoff now
scientists aren't exactly sure why
binging triggers this kind of
inflammatory response but there is some
evidence that it's more severe when you
drink darker alcohols in one study
participants who drank bourbon instead
of vodka reported that their hangover
symptoms were 36% worse the next morning
then there's that awful morning anxiety
called anxiety and no it's not the guilt
that you feel from all the bad decisions
you made the night before it's actually
biological hang xiety starts to develop
when you finally put down that last
empty cocktail glass you see up until
that point your brain has been ramping
up the activity of receptors called GA
ba giving you that calming buzz
and at the same time it's been blocking
glutamate a stimulant linked to anxiety
but when you stop drinking that whole
system flips right around your brain
empties those calming G ABA receptors
and floods with stimulating glutamate
which can make you feel abnormally
anxious by the time morning comes around
it can also disrupt your sleep so you
wake up still tired but enough of all
that bad news you want to know how you
can make that nasty hangover a thing of
the past
sorry to say but that delicious greasy
breakfast isn't doing you any favors
your body is running low on water not
fat so your best bet is to hydrate and
take an anti-inflammatory
chances are the hangover will vanish
within 24 hours or at least in time for
next weekend hello my good friend yes
I'd love to go to the big party and I
will be drinking a lot of alcohol as
well